the media rushing to defend joe biden as
he pushes the same old tired plan to
deal with a new coven variant the
president implementing new testing
requirements adding additional mandates
and of course telling americans to mask
up and get their boosters
now he's complaining that kovad has
become too politicized as if he had
nothing to do with it
it's a plan that i think should unite us
i know cover 19 has been very divisive
in this country it's become a political
issue which is a sad sad commentary
it shouldn't be but it has been
this is a moment we can do what we
haven't been able to do enough of
through this whole pandemic get the
nation to come together
unite the nation and a common purpose
to fight this virus to protect one
another to protect our economic recovery
and to think of it in terms of literally
a patriotic responsibility rather than
somehow you're denying people their
basic rights
sure
joe claims that the pandemic has been
politicized which is hilarious coming
from a guy who told people not to trust
a vaccine
because it was coming from a republican
president how many people died because
of that political smear and predictably
the media going into overdrive to give
biden cover for his latest failures
they see political advantage
in kobe continuing to be a problem
because they know it hurts joe biden
they see the political advantage in in
in coven continuing because they know it
hurts the economy they think that if
kobe goes on longer it puts them in a
better political position to win in 2020
do people fall off
there's likelier a chance that covent
will go away and if cova goes away it's
bad right now for republicans it's just
the math on this the political math and
this is not hard to figure out
yeah don't worry the white house has a
reassuring message to the american
people just do more
whatever happened to president biden's
promise to shut down the virus
we're working on it peter but we need
the american people to do
more who are not vaccinated to help us
continue to fight the virus
dana
how can he accuse anyone of politicizing
the pandemic when that was the game plan
for all of 2020 including telling people
that i wouldn't get the vaccine because
it came from trump not only that
remember and even after he was elected
and he's in office remember how he used
to go after states like florida and
arizona and say basically that they were
like merchants of death because they
when they were the problem then it turns
out well the statistics change but they
never say they were sorry for saying
such a thing um the idea that covet is
good for the republican party is
hilarious to me
look the party literally lost the white
house and the senate
over cobid so i don't know whether he
hasn't talked to a republican in three
years everybody wants the virus to go
away um i i believe that truly that
everyone does um
the thing that is kind of shocking is
that when president joe biden says
i'm going to crush the virus and then
you start blaming everybody else right
that is hard to take and i i i agree
that you know more vaccines are a good
idea but i also think that jumping the
gun on this omnicron omicron
variant is going way too far too fast
until we know more it could be
that because it's more mild and because
it transmits more easily to more people
more people will have immunity and then
we should be able to have some sort of
you know leeway to get back to normal
like today the tsa just announced that
we're gonna have to wear masks on planes
until march 18th 2022. and probably
beyond there because it feels like that
will never end it's just it is there
these are cowards chasing
risks out of fear of litigation that's
all this is uh jessica i have a question
it's a multiple choice question for you
guess it's gonna be really fair can we
put the question up there please uh
is joe biden racist with blood on his
hands
a yes
b
of course
c a and b
d all of the above
i i feel like the producers like you
more than me
you get these like handy things and i'm
just left out here with my notes
um
none of the above obvious e uh new
invention to your game um
so a couple of things i think were
really important in what joe biden was
talking about beyond the politicization
of it and i would say of course that
he and kamala harris were both talking
about a trump recommendation versus a
scientist recommendation but the
increase in testing sites and the
reimbursement for home testing kits is
going to be really crucial here the
difference in price between how much it
costs for us to get a test versus in
mainland europe in germany you can get a
home test for one euro
here it's 24 that's a huge differential
so making this more equitable so that
people can not only get vaccinated and
get boosted which seems like the key to
keeping yourself healthy with the delta
variant which seems much more powerful
than omicron
and having these cheaper kits is going
to make a huge difference so i was
really thrilled to see that yeah
all right we'll let you slide on that
one
this seems to be the only administration
that passes the buck onto the american
people it's always on us to do more
i've always said that you have to pass
the book to china and that's so obvious
i don't know why joe doesn't take my
political advice
speaking of political advice i'd like to
talk about john heilman yeah how you
pronounce his name jesse jr has spit up
more cogent analysis than what i just
heard this guy whatever he's getting
paid is overpaid i'm confident in saying
that
joe biden
the only thing keeping him in the low
40s is kovid you get rid of kovid he's
in the 30s and the 20s on inflation
crime immigration you don't think the
republican party wants to knock out
kovid second of all covet is his excuse
for everything he blames smash and grab
robberies on kovid supply chain crisis
on covet you knock out kovat you knock
out all of his excuses
you remember how much mileage joe biden
got politically by going after desantis
when cases were high in florida now
cases are dead low in florida you think
desantis is sitting around in the
governor's mansion hoping for a winter
surge
for political purposes of course not
republicans don't want a permanent
pandemic we don't want to see fouchy on
tv anymore republicans want fouchy in
prison it's the democrats that want the
permanent pandemic they're the ones who
wanted to shut the schools and the small
businesses and use the thing as an
excuse to bail out the blue states and
spend trillions of dollars republicans
don't want cases to go up democrats will
just use that an excuse to grow
government and i don't know if he's
spoken to a republican recently
republicans don't act like there is a
pandemic anymore we haven't after we've
been baxed and a lot of us weren't
before we were back we were going to
holiday parties we were at the beach we
were flying go outside john heilman
see someone with a double mask and a
face shield on that is a democrat that
is not a republican all right and
i'm not an nbc news political animus i'm
just a new york times number one
best-selling author yeah that is the
best analysis i can do and and i don't
think heilman is a best-selling author i
think he's he's deluded himself into
that role of trying to outdo
something previously hysterical that he
said because when he gets a reaction on
tv for saying something nutso then the
next time he has to up the ante it gets
into this weird cycle this happens to
what's called midwits you know what a
midwit is it's not a nitwit it's not an
idiot but it's not a smart person so
heilman is a midwit he's right in the
middle there's not a real thing yes it's
a real thing you can look it up in any
science book
any dictionary yes
well i would say any time a politician
pretends to be god it goes poorly for
them and a lot of them do this so barack
obama said he was going to calm the
rising seas president biden said that he
was going to take out the virus and here
we are now there are more deaths under
his watch than we're under trump which
is something the media doesn't have
tickers on their screens to count every
single day for but on the issue of
politics when i was listening to him
speak today at the nih and when i read
the white house readout and the details
of what he was going to say i noticed
that there is an emphasis on keeping
schools open
so long as parents vaccinate their
children now there have been a number of
stories in places like the new york
times saying lots of parents got
vaccinated but they actually have
concerns and questions about running out
and vaccinating their children and yet
today you have
the president saying we'll keep schools
open so long as now given the track
record of that with the teachers unions
randy weingarten for example who tweeted
about how these
these new this new plan is necessary to
keep schools open safely for all of the
kids to get vaccinated i would watch
that and see what the teachers unions do
if parents decide that they're not quite
ready for that and whether they again
try to extort the system and say well
then we're not going to go into the
classrooms because we don't feel like
it's safe because they did that for so
long and of course they were pushing the
cdc around on opening guidance earlier
this year hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else